frankfort is a lot cozier than these
cyclists from hamburg ever imagined they
like the local apple wine and they're
proud that a german city could become
the e u--'s new financial capital it
could have been Berlin or Hamburg but
there's more money here it has nothing
to do with size it's all about
competence and knowledge and Frankfurt
has what it takes or distinguish one
does come for technique for staggering
north this is a record-setting location
no sooner had the British voted to leave
the EU then marketing agency Frankfurt
mine finance put up a website showing
what the city has to offer everything
from tax advantages to English language
schools the website aims to attract
highly qualified staff from London to
Frankfurt was given a fantastic eaten
possible the infrastructure is fantastic
with the airport and we have the largest
internet exchange point in Europe
seventy-five percent of our banks are
international forty percent of residents
come from other countries it's a
cosmopolitan city but is Frankfurt
really the new promising financial
capital of Europe the city has less than
1 million inhabitants 70,000 people here
work in the financial sector compared to
700,000 in London but there's one big
attraction for foreign banks the
European Central Bank has its
headquarters in Frankfurt 10,000 bankers
could move to Frankfurt according to
some estimates they would need offices
and homes that might give another boost
to the real estate market prices have
already been rising for years one real
estate agent talked to bankers in London
he doesn't expect much like it's also an
wars are hostia people say Germany is no
longer a top location it's all about
labour laws which are too strict about
there are better locations in Poland or
India no matter how many banks might
come the Frankfurt Stock Exchange has
already taken a big step it would like
to merge with the London Stock Exchange
to be more powerful internationally but
the Germans are making demands the
headquarters should no longer be in
London but in
frankfort still brokers say brexit is
not a good thing it impacts it it's the
specs it is the worst thing I could have
imagined it is completely unsettled the
world what's next for the EU could the
EU totally fall apart nobody knows at
least twice money's one thing won't
change the apple wine in frankfurt pubs
come what may people here know how to
enjoy life